uh so there's this show on netflix
called squid game
that
is apparently right now and netflix is
not very forthcoming with this sort of
information about how many people are
actually watching
their their programs i mean for all we
know you know their top show has like 10
viewers and we would never know because
they don't tell us
but they have told us proudly that this
show squid game is their i think right
now their most popular show across the
world on streaming everybody's watching
this thing well here's the
story from the daily mail dubbing squid
game the most twisted series on tv
it says a gruesome netflix horror series
about a fictional deadly game show in
which poverty-stricken characters
compete battle royale style to win a 27
million cash prize has come under fire
from viewers over its unnecessary gore
and violence
korean made squid game which is the most
streamed show in the u.s and in the uk
features grisly scenes of characters
being shot in the head in organ
harvesting in the latest example of
shock tactic programming from the
streaming giant
uh it's become a cult hit with fans i
don't know if you can call it a cult hit
when it's the most widely viewed show on
streaming right now uh more of a
mainstream hit with fans of the slash
the slasher horror genre who have dubbed
the nine part series saw meets the
hunger games and reveled in scenes of
torture and mass murder
um
but some tv fans have been left repulsed
by the excessive violence with several
saying they could not even make it
through the first episode and others
recommending it be banned for viewers
under 20 because it's too gory
and then it goes into
uh graphic descriptions i probably don't
need to read in each episode of squid
game characters take part in bloody
versions of traditional children's games
like grandmother's footsteps or british
bulldogs with the winners
progressing to the next round of the
game show the loser losers are executed
by a masked death squad standing by with
machine guns
but
i guess
does add some extra intensity to a to a
to jeopardy or to a game show if that's
the way they're doing it um and then it
goes into graphic descriptions of what
the show
depicts and
i don't need to get into that
you know i haven't having having not
watched the show and i don't plan on
watching it
um
it does bring up this conversation about
violence in shows and in windows that go
too far
there's a there's a tendency
um among people i think on both sides
really
to say that uh but we try to say this
about entertainment in general whether
it's sexual content or violent content
and we say it's just entertainment it
doesn't have any effect on anybody come
on
that's silly what what so i'm going to
watch squid game and then go out and
join a death squad and start executing
people you think that's what i'm gonna
do
people do the same thing with
pornography and this is really like a
form of porn this is this is torture
porn
which seems to be coming back into
popularity i remember when i was a when
i was a teenager that was a big genre
that things like uh
like like saw uh there's a movie called
hostile and other movies where
that was the whole attraction to the the
film you went you watched people get
tortured for 95 minutes and then you
left and there's really no plot that's
just all that happened
and um
it seems like those kinds of shows
dipped in popularity but are now surging
back into popularity so it's a kind of
it's a kind of pornography it's torture
porn
and with actual sexual pornography you
hear the same kind of thing the people
defending it saying i'm not what i'm
going to watch poor or anything i'm
going to go out and become a rapist come
on that's ridiculous
yeah when you
if you if you if you want to be
reductive about it
and try to draw these simplistic
dots and connect them that directly then
yeah it seems silly like no one is is
suggesting that you're going to watch a
show like squid game and then go out and
kill people directly as a result
that would that would be an absurd thing
to suggest but no one's suggesting it
it's just as absurd to suggest that
you're not influenced at all
by the images and messages and ideas
that you sit there passively
eating your doritos and drooling
and ingesting
that is also absurd of course it has an
effect on you
we're human beings we have minds we're
we are affected by all of the messages
and images
that we come in contact with the
advertising industry is ba if we're not
affected by by images and messages and
ideas then the advertising industry
wouldn't exist
and with that with advertisements they
can influence you in 30 seconds
they can influence you with a with a
billboard you see on the highway
for three seconds as you're driving by
that's how
impressionable how easily influenced we
are
and so i do worry about that
with pornography of course and i worry
about that with with
with gratuitous violence in films and in
shows
and when i say gratuitous that doesn't
mean that every single show and movie we
watch has to be rated g you know i don't
i don't think that at all some of my
favorite films of all time saving
private ryan one of my favorite films
extremely violent
i think what makes it gratuitous
is when
almost all of the entertainment value
is in watching people
be mutilated and
and killed in all of these gory and
graphic ways when when that is the
entertainment you know if violence is
part of the story you're watching a war
film
violence is part of the story you can't
take violence out of that if you're
going to take violence out of a of a war
story you might as well not tell the
story at all
but when the whole story is the violence
and the entertainment value isn't
watching people
be ripped open and uh and disemboweled
that's when it becomes gratuitous
and that's when you have to
worry about the kind of influence that
has on us
and i think the primary influence is not
that it's turning people into murderers
uh it's just it's just a it's
desensitization it's moral
desensitization
which is also one of the primary
influences of pornography
it's not that it causes you to go out
and do things kind of the opposite it
just it just
turns you into this sort of blank slate
and you become desensitized to these
kinds of images
and even though it's fictional
right if you're watching someone
be disemboweled in squid game
it's fictional
but if you're sitting there watching it
and enjoying it
you do have to ask yourself why do i
enjoy watching this
even though it's fictional what is it
about this
because part of enjoying a fictional
story when you're watching a show part
of the enjoyment aspect is to forget
that it's fictional if you have in your
mind the whole time oh this is fictional
this is fictional then you can't enjoy
it that's called breaking the fourth
wall right
so you have to surrender your mind to
this story
and get into the mentality sort of
pretend that it's not fictional so then
you have to ask yourself what is it
about that that i enjoy watching
it is feeding a part of me
that probably should not be fed
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends